well hello there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here hey John how are you
I'm good man I'm fantastic how are you
sir in there was that we're trying to do
that was wrong okay
ladies and gentlemen if you could leave
a like on this video that'd be very much
appreciated listen we tried shooting
this at the theater they wouldn't allow
it we tried shooting outside it was way
too dark you just wouldn't be able to
see us we try shooting in the parking
lot at the movie theater security guard
there nice guy wasn't a fan of what we
were doing rushed back here and uh now
we're in the backyard shooting this when
we could be inside like pros in the
studio everything just a regular video
but we wanted to maintain some of the
Integrity already just watched video so
as opposed to seeing it just five
minutes ago like we normally do now
we've seen it 20 minutes ago so it's not
that big of a difference it's a big
difference John since I know I got a lot
to get off my chest here what's the plot
of the movie you know it's a few years
after end game Scott Lang is now an
author he's capitalizing on his his
Avengers Fame but his daughter Cassie
Lang is a rebellious teenager now she's
Landing herself in jail which of course
is is just funny it's not a really big
deal no consequences to that so she's
doing great she builds this machine that
accidentally gets them all sucked into
the quantum realm where Janet's like no
I hate it here and I don't want to talk
about it I want to tell you anything
about it for half the movie I'm gonna
draw out the suspense for something we
already know is coming and then Kang's
here he's gonna set up phase five and he
needs some McGuffin so he can break out
of you know the quantum realm and
there's Shenanigans and stuff hopes in
the background here and there Hank is
along for the ride that's pretty much it
alrighty look there's a lot of things
that I want to talk about with this
movie a good amount we can't talk about
that is non-spoiler there's a lot that
we can't talk about that is very spoiler
heavy a lot of those things that I take
gripe with with this movie that I
imagine you do too because we didn't
talk to each other at all during the
movie no and what I was surprised by was
when the movie was done I was like ah
great this is gonna be one of those
films where I'm going to be arguing with
John and he's going to be telling me
what he loves about it and I'm going to
be like oh no here's why I don't like
this part of the movie man oh wow to my
surprise from the brief time we talked
about it we're I think we're on the same
page we had the same anxiety
I bottom line
overall it was fine and I know normally
when you say something like that people
will yell at you going why don't you
just say it's bad and what you want to
say what you really feel and I will tell
you what I really feel I had a lot of
issues with this movie would it be a lie
for me to say that there weren't parts
of this movie that I did really enjoy I
would even say there's a solid 30
minutes of this film that I was very
much engaged with you know the part on
the trailers when Ant-Man and Kang meet
each other a little bit before that and
like 20 minutes after that there's a
specific chunk of the movie where I was
like okay finally this movie's really
it's really got me I'm I'm in I'm really
in and then it started to lose me again
and the finale of this film especially
started losing me I know normally in
reviews you want to like get all the
good points first and then you go into
the negatives it's gonna be this is
going to be a very serious discussion
run in the middle of the album it's good
well yeah the movie's not exactly like a
three act or even a five act structure
it was like a 10x structure of this
movie
most of it feels like act two somehow
it's very strange it's a paradox it is a
paradox of sorts okay so the first thing
that people probably want you to talk
about right King the Conqueror Jonathan
Majors how is he well I can tell you
that I think Jonathan Majors did an
excellent job with the material that he
was given I think he really elevates the
material it's really important for me to
emphasize the word Elevate I'm not
exactly a hundred percent thrilled about
King the Conqueror in total if that
makes sense again a lot of it to really
describe it would be very spoilery I'll
just tell you some afterthought opinions
I'm not exactly thrilled at the prospect
of Kang being the uh big Baddie of phase
five because while this movie really
seems to step out of its way to not
really be an Ant-Man movie a lot of time
but really set up phase five it does a
great job at setting up phase five it
really does sure because you're like all
right at least get what phase five is
going towards I can see threads coming
together I can see Clarity like you
mentioned when we came out of the movie
there's some clarity from phase four
coming into this especially a lot of
visual motifs and some lines of dialogue
where I'm like I'm even seeing some of
phase four actually clicking together so
they must have heard all the complaints
people were having or like make sure
this [__] is clear they live service to
interconnectivity
here making it clear while I think he
brings a lot of Gravitas to it the way
they execute the character and what they
give him to do in this film I didn't
find him scary I thought a lot of what
they chose to do with his movie really
undercuts him as a threat I really think
Scarlet Witch could I think if you watch
this movie I I don't feel like there's a
question in your mind that you'd be like
Scarlet Witch could whip this guy's ass
yeah so why would I be excited about
like The Avengers having to deal with
this guy because this movie also goes
out of its way a lot to be like he's
hyper intelligent he's so smart he's so
threatening he's unspeakable movie never
really shows you despite the fact that
when he is talking it is the most
engaging Yet the movie never really
gives you an insight as to how and then
the way the movie progresses I'm like
this guy this is the dude you've been
building up for so long it was also
going gonna have his own Dynasty later
yeah that's probably gonna be the most
unpopular opinion out there because I'm
sure everyone's raving because again he
does a great job no it's the rest of the
movie the writing and the direction
doesn't necessarily bolster it doesn't
help his performance more than he's
helping out everything else around him
and on top of that that creates this
sort of teetering between what could be
a real formidable villain who presents a
harrowing set of stakes versus something
that starts to feel a bit like a costume
party that's turned angry the
mid-credits scene I bet if we go online
right now there's a lot of people hyping
up this mid credits yes there are there
are you looked I've seen a few responses
and I've seen people be like oh man that
made credit scenes
scene was
a joke it like feels quite silly if I
were to tell you what it is contextually
you'd be like
awesome that's what I was hoping for
yeah contextually the way it's executed
was
like an SNL sketch to me meets the
ending of the Planet of the Apes movie
with Mark Wahlberg it's not like that
ending but it has that Vibe of that
ending like I think it's real cool it's
supposed to be like really cool and
serious and setting something up and I'm
like this is just so so silly and people
were laughing in the screening where
we're at I bet not at the movie premiere
they weren't laughing but at the screen
we were rap people you couldn't hear any
of the dialogue to know over the
cheering I can't wait to talk about it
because that was a really cringy I mean
credits yes that's a good way to put
that yeah it does feel like they rented
out a warehouse for an afternoon and
tacked something on well that's supposed
to be the major punctuation on this
movie and yeah it feels very much like
it must have something to do with
Spider-Man yeah I like it it does give
you that sort of stilted vibe I mean the
post-credits scene is good yes it is
ruin it but it's obviously Peyton Reed
didn't do it
yeah it's a bit detached from the
immediate proceedings that was what
elicited the most from the audience in a
lot of ways it is one of the most
interesting moments the entire movie
gives you is at the very end of the
credits with this film there's there's
no real struggle and I don't mean that
just emotionally there's no real
conflict the most engaging way for for
most movies is if there's an external
struggle and they have to like go
through it and then they change as a
person like how does this experience of
going toe-to-toe with the villain change
them as an individual what do they have
to overcome there's none of that in this
movie that's a movie that on Surface
might be like this is the weirdest MCU
movie ever it's about as old Marvel
generic as you can get there's not a lot
of stakes in this movie feel like it
feels like they really prioritized plot
over everything else and setups over
everything else in a way that makes it
feel like there's a ton going on there's
lots of stuff happening and yet not much
is really achieving any kind of momentum
it keeps Shifting the plot around
there's like 10 acts in this movie I
never really had time to get invested in
something enough to worry about it to
fear for it to be concerned about it and
then when they finally set up a plot
that you see kind of teased in the
trailer I'm like okay well we're now
we're at the end of the movie it really
feels like Peyton Reed's desire not to
be the palette cleanser movie and to
instead be the Avengers level movie has
really worked against it because on the
one hand I feel like that could equate
to some interesting strides for the
Ant-Man Trilogy and it doesn't funny
enough feel like the third installment
in the Ant-Man Trilogy really at all
making it this Avengers level set of
stakes kind of took a lot of the
personality and a lot of the actual
scope and scale like if you look back on
the previous Ant-Man movies this doesn't
need to be that but it's tempered by the
real world and the changing of size of
familiar objects the this almost does
none of that and it also pairs down the
humor and I feel like you could have
made an Avengers level movie with that
level of impact out of Ant-Man and use
that as an opportunity to hoist a a more
B level or less successful character
into the main Spotlight this is the most
I've felt like the VFX team did just
direct the movie based off the notes
that whatever the interconnectivityness
like required and Modoc Modoc is the
thing that I feel will be really hated I
don't hate Modoc in this movie I think I
kind of enjoyed him he's one of the
things I like more and is actually a bit
weird about the movie it's weird it's
like when it first is presented you're
like that is it's awful this is a weird
looking they play into it in the script
in the actual reactions from the like
they react more to Modoc than they do
anything else in this one seriously they
react more to him because he is weird
he's got the Dead Eye effect old CGI and
I'm like but maybe that's intentional I
I don't know he's not threatening he's
not scary whatsoever he is just a joke
but he had two moments in this movie two
specific lines of dialogue I could think
of those were some of the funniest I
laughed in the whole film absolutely as
much as I know this character will
definitely upset people he made me laugh
that was one of the most intentional
things about this movie was to not take
him seriously and they didn't take him
seriously and then they leaned into that
I know there's going to be a lot of
people who don't like it and will think
it's one of the worst things Marvel's
ever done but screw it at least
something intentionally was like yeah at
least I laughed at that you know Paul
Rudd is good uh as always he's good he's
Paul Rudd he gets more dramatic work to
do here than he did in any of the other
films we've seen him do and I I thought
he was believable in those moments
Cassie Lang I like Katherine Newton the
actress uh quite a bit and I'm not gonna
lie I imagine there'd be a lot of people
with a lot of problems with her again
it's one of these situations where I'm
like I enjoy Catherine Newton there's so
much about the execution in the writing
the storytelling of this character wow
what a convenient experience this movie
is so full with visual effects but
there's no sense of awe or wonder okay
let's look at Hank pin I get if you've
seen some [__] and he's not like exactly
he's entirely thrown off base but he
should be at least a little fascinated
by what's going on so should wasp but
especially Cassie laying there should at
least be some sense of a horror glim
Steven is a smidge of what this world
could be beyond our own yeah yeah Beyond
just having Yellow Jacket come into her
room and then five year disappear
because the quantum realm is nothing
like that's a whole different thing yeah
yeah yeah you just gotta sucked through
a Vortex into the atoms beneath atoms
you should at least have a reaction to
that and beyond that neither John or I
are a fan of this phrase
I'm going to have to say it though
because I can't really think of anything
more efficiently to describe it at this
moment in time there is the Mary Sue
effect that people often say where I
normally don't agree with its
application of that word I'm like yeah
it's it's reasons like this why why this
word exists yeah because the truth of
the matter for me is it's not even like
I got annoyed it was like I could feel
the movie removing opportunities for
itself to have impactful character
moments with Cassie and with Scott
together and her growth as a character
because too it's the first time we're
seeing Cassie in this capacity as a
potential young Avenger and stuff like
that and it's the first time that we're
getting to witness her you know
experiencing all this stuff and yet the
movie Maneuvers her into a place where
everything's just cool and she's just
kind of got this and No Matter What
conflict comes her way everyone around
her is like nah you're fine it's fine
you're good even Scott with his minor
disciplinary dad dude just is a cool you
know the trailers really made it seem
like that it was something about I
really want time with my my daughter
back King's giving me an offer that's
the way the trailers pitched it yeah
that's not the movie they set you up
like Cassie and and Scott must have like
a strained messed up relationship or
something he's been gone and she's
fallen on the wrong path man oh you're
like not really he's gonna walk pretty
well so with that there's no character
Arc in this movie at all it's pretty
much Scott has not been doing heroic
stuff lately now he's doing something
heroic yeah yeah it's been a while since
the last Avengers level threat now Scott
has a new Avengers level threat Janet
they're setting her up for she's got to
confront the demons from her past but
that kind of just gets no she needs to
hold on to Exposition until it's time to
give it out it just gets completely lost
in the mix they lose a lot of
opportunities for multiple characters to
have actual emotional beats and arcs and
it's funny because I've seen a lot of
people respond to this thing it's such a
heartwarming father-daughter story and
that's all I was hoping for it was a
surface cute level yeah like I said
everything went to the fine level like
you just don't know what to care about
you get thrust into the quantum realm
and you see that in the trailer they got
all this like Civilization of people and
stuff they just keep saying [__] like
Kang's bad he did stuff to our people
and I think there's like a line in there
that says what he did the movie never
lets you get to actually know these
people and a big part of it is wanting
to start an uprising in a revolution so
you don't feel for it why would I care
they even have this setup in here where
Scott is like we just got to get out of
here but Cassie's like no Dad we gotta
help these people and you never get a
moment the slightest spoiler I'm gonna
give you is you never get a moment where
you see Scott being like you're right we
gotta help you we owe it to these people
yeah whatever becomes about that but it
becomes a focus of the film but I'm like
I never got to know these people I don't
know why I should care about this the
movie just shows you a lot of like weird
designs of the quantum realm you don't
really get to know the quantum realm and
they keep seeing Kings in like this
oppressive thing when you go around the
city it looks like you guys are living a
regular normal lives like the worst the
Kings got are these security guard
Androids which suck by the way they are
ineffective how is this the Master Level
scientist guy when he builds the weakest
henchman because he has no formidable
challengers in this realm that's why
he's revered as this crazy warlord is
because there's no competition they
don't show you the occupation and they
don't really give you any taste of what
life is like down here under this
oppression or what the oppression even
looks like or extends to I know that
that's the cliche you have a big Baddie
got a bunch of henchmen who you just
kick and punch I know that's a cliche
but this is the guy who they've been
saying is this highest level intellect
genius but I'm like Ultron did better in
a day then all this time you've been
here banished out here for decades upon
decades it's not difficult to keep up
with I really feel like the movie just
needed like an extra 30 minutes just so
we could have some much needed scenes to
help these emotional moments land more
otherwise it's just another movie where
a lot of people walk away from going
like yeah cool action and it sets up
phase five well really I think a lot of
the best Marvel movies are always
setting up the future of Marvel but
that's only a percentage of the film
where this seemed like its main intent
was to set up the future I wasn't
personally like yeah people often
complain about green screen heavy movies
but this really stood out to me because
as impressive as the visual effects are
there are scenes like when they
especially when they first go into the
quantum realm one thing I'll get paid
and read credit for was I love the
choice of when to use music and when to
not use music because a lot of the times
these movies could be quite bombastic
with music to really try to enhance the
experience but a lot of the time there
was no music and I thought that was
better and it made a lot of the sound
design zeroed in a lot better for a lot
of these key sequences because all the
visual effects are great that scene
where you see multiple Ant-Man and stuff
what a cool sequence it was a fantastic
sequence it was amazing occasionally a
few wonky moments of what movie would
not have some wonky VFX once in a while
it's as great as visuals can be that
stuff can wear thin after a while
because it just starts becoming like a
lot of noise the thing that I felt the
most that this movie was was like I was
standing in line for an Avengers ride
and then they had these like special
clips to watch while you're waiting in
line and I had the feeling like oh cool
they got the actors to show up for this
but you know when the actors show up for
that [__] they're not giving it their
right
Everything feels a little more green
screeny in one of those Riot videos and
here even it feels like everyone's just
kind of in a big Warehouse with a bunch
of Animation around them and even the
way that it's shot is kind of that like
ah we didn't really have that much time
so just keep it into basic coverage and
some basic wide shots and that's about
it as cool as everything looks it seems
to lack again I keep using the word
Wonder it's easy to just say style over
substance but that's really what it is
this style is is the people who created
the visuals and created the the the the
makeup and stuff that's the style
somehow this movie does not make you
make you feel lived in it does not feel
immersive there's no emotional struggle
and there's no physical struggle and
that's a big problem I think with Peyton
Reed directing the actors or just not
knowing what to do for example if you're
running through chaos and everyone's
just running like they've been told to
run they got like a straight face like
just like you don't look like you're in
the middle of a battle or in the finale
no spoilers these are just humans and
they're zipping around town freaking
fighting left and right running running
running and then by the end of the fight
when the storms calm down you know
helmets come off or whatever they just
look like super clean no breathing heavy
not a single sweat they're just like
super polished and yeah we're standing
in front of a green screen doing our
scene there's no weight either
emotionally or physically the
hand-to-hand fight that you see in the
trailer with King and and but that's the
most physical struggle that takes
obviously a long time to get there it
finally gets bloodied up and that does
look intense and painful yeah too little
too late but the big thing though is
this is the first Ant-Man movie with
this cast that you're bringing over and
paid in redirecting that is primarily in
front of a green screen a big part of
why especially there were no stakes and
this was something I did not expect to
say about this film I felt there was no
Stakes or no sense of urgency really
came down to some of the performances in
this film Michael Douglas as Hank Pym is
not the same Hank pin at all like it
feels like some random old guy who was
told all his lines before they said
action there was so much of the time
where it was clearly obvious that they
didn't know how to direct direct people
like Evangeline Lilly and Michael
Douglas because they clearly had no clue
what they were looking at yeah and a lot
of even the continuity character-wise
from the previous movies doesn't fully
carry over it feels like Hank Pym got
like a Xanax prescription and chilled
way out between movies or something like
that and yeah Evangeline Lilly her job
is mainly just to be flustered a lot of
the time and maybe deal a punch it's
called Ant-Man and the wasp and I'm like
you should just call this Ant-Man and
King she's called Ant-Man Cassie the
king you guys are easy to call this
movie of all the ant family hope does
feel the most tacked on in the least
sort of spotlighted like Michael Douglas
was I was kind of astounded by how he
was just walking through the film
because I really feel like what's going
on the performer who got more screen
time this time around and I thought did
a great job and was the one who actually
brought intensity who actually seemed
comfortable working in this environment
was Michelle Pfeiffer as Janet obviously
she had been in the quantum realm for
quite some time and her character set up
in a way where she's very much
traumatized from her experiences there
so she doesn't want anyone exploring in
the quantum realm but I did have a
thought when I was watching this because
she's so much like you shouldn't be
looking in this evening
I'm near it but then I was going I
thought in the post-credits scene for
Ant-Man and the WASP she was totally
sending Scott Lang in there into the
quantum realm to collect energy to help
ghosts stabilize herself through the
quantum tunnel continuity wise this
doesn't even line up with the last time
I saw this woman it doesn't even make
any sense right now but let's ignore
that for a moment it sets up her
character in this way to like overcome
and see like what really went down here
I actually really like the flashbacks
that you get to see with Janet I thought
they were really strong and very
engaging that was part of the 30 minute
chunk that I was talking about where you
do really get to explore some of that
and I thought that was really engrossing
there is humor in it like there were
times I really laughed but a lot of
times the humor feels like they're
afraid to commit to the overall
seriousness of a particular moment so
they're trying to inject some humor
sometimes it's genuinely funny a lot of
the time it does have that clear cut
effect of they felt like they needed to
infuse a joke in here when they didn't
need to infuse a joke don't get me wrong
there are some there are some moments
where I was like that was hilarious
there's a couple moments where I thought
were really really funny yeah it was
fine it's another fine evening I would
not call this movie terrible it's
definitely not a glowing but the
brightness does make you especially
frustrated I think I think it's one of
those where it's pretty okay in a way
that leaves you really kind of
aggravated by all the potential that was
very visibly missed yeah because I think
part of the burnout that some people
probably feel after phase four is like a
lot of phase four I think for the most
part A lot of it isn't isn't terrible
it's just a lot of it is kind of like I
kind of suffered thinking about it once
it's done and I was like this movie
should not be doing that no at least and
you know what we're pretty big marbles
so this is the Prime movie especially
for me as a viewer this is the Prime
movie where I want to go in and just
have fun with it and look past any
whatever flaws to the things I love
about an Ant-Man movie and the
excitement for Kang to come and it
fumbled that that so I was especially
taken aback because I was like this
should have been an easy slam dunk on me
as a viewer same here I I really thought
that this would have easily been yeah I
got some flaws we'll go into them but
mainly here oh here's everything I
thought it was gonna be like the easiest
thing to talk about but I was like this
really
surprised me just how middleweight
beautiful was it's reasonably enjoyable
throughout this is not the best I could
give it with some moments that really
truly shine but anyway
all right well
we're done see you guys thanks for being
here